once you're aware of a thought it loses
its power to have a feeling over you
based on the science there is only a
90-second chemical release in your body
it's called the 90-second rule
i was annoyed by how all the journalists
asked all the athletes the same stupid
question
literally everyone wanna be happy build
a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you have michael jordan level genius at
something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the six habits you must
learn to thrive
under pressure enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one align your thoughts and feelings
with ed mylett
i'm a huge believer in the power of
intention and awareness so when these
negative thoughts creep in whatever they
are fear
i'm aware of my own thinking and once
you're aware of a thought
it loses its power to have a feeling
over you this is what most people don't
understand so we're all going to have
those thoughts like oh i'm losing my dad
it's a horrible thing when you're aware
of that negative thought
the feeling loses its power over you one
of the things that
i think people need to start to
understand is if you don't align your
thoughts and your feelings neither one
has any power there has to be a
congruency between what you're thinking
and what you're feeling that's why like
for example when people set up all these
goals i'm going to make a million
dollars or i'm gonna go to the nfl or
i'm gonna be happier i'm gonna lose 20
pounds
in the moment you're having that thought
if you're feeling that you can't have it
if you're feeling that's not going to
happen your body which is your
unconscious mind actually at work
the feeling overrides the thought and
that goal has no power
so if you can begin to visualize what
your goals are and allow yourself to
feel it
in the present time and there's the gift
i'll give you
if you could already experience
gratitude for an event or a goal that
has not
yet happened but you can experience the
gratitude so when you have these
visualizations you probably know you
were doing it when you played
but you're visualizing the catch you're
visualizing the celebration you're
already in a gratitude state about
having received the goal you have
now you've aligned and congruence your
feelings with your thoughts
now you're a powerful mfr but what most
people do in their life is they either
have the conscious thoughts
overwritten by they're like lack i have
never done this before i'm not going to
do it i've always been 20 pounds
overweight i don't have a million
dollars in the bank
and they write down all these goals that
aren't linked with the feeling people
say well how do i get the feeling you
get the feeling by having gratitude for
the event before it's happened
habit number two make fear your
superpower with lewis howes
when you face some type of adversity or
challenge where your your identity is
shifted and rocked
it is a scary time because i had to look
at
every fear swear to god for the next
three years of my life matthew for that
i faced i looked at every fear i wrote
them all down on the list my biggest
fears and i just said
these things have power and control over
me and i need to become
like batman and live in a cage
with all these fears and until i can
stand up and see all my fears around me
and be able to stand up with power with
command
and not be afraid of all the fear not be
afraid of the bats
hitting my face but actually embrace the
bats
and take it all on and that's what i did
for the next three to five years
i wrote down a list of my biggest fears
i did them all
one by one and it was miserable i was
afraid of public speaking so i did it
every week for a year i was afraid of
salsa dancing so i did it every week for
years
i was afraid to sing in public all these
things i was afraid of i said
no longer will they have power over me
and um
i was afraid to launch a business afraid
to do an interview show all these things
i just kept doing my fears and made
those fears a superpower and i think
that's what's helped me along my career
good book by my man evan carmichael
built to serve if you want to learn
about your purpose and how to become a
better leader in the world i love this
he says
this is the starting point for
everything if you're confused about what
to do next if you're pressured by others
to fit in or live
their version of your life if you feel
held back because of people judging you
it's because you don't know who you are
and what you stand for
you got to figure out who you are what
you want and how you can serve
other people habit number three use the
90-second rule with mel robbins
here's the other interesting piece of
science you know that
wave that you feel or your tongue gets
numb or you get tightness in your cheeks
or you freeze you know when that happens
based on the science there is only a
90-second
chemical release in your body it's
called the 90 second rule
when your body starts to stomach starts
to flutter when your heart starts to
race when you feel this feeling of fear
that you have that's unique to you
based on the science there's a 90-second
rule and
all of the chemical release that's
happening because your body is going
into a state of being alert
it only sticks around for 90 seconds
as long as you don't let your thoughts
race if your thoughts start to race
you'll start to agitate the situation so
what we want you to do what i want you
to do
and if you go to melrons.com take
control
and you download the 55-page workbook
that goes with our audiobook that is the
number one new release on audible called
take
control how to silence fear and win the
mental game
if you look on pages 12 and 13 of the
workbook
there's a long list of
things that you can do to slow your body
response to fear down
so the next time that your body goes
into a state of alert
stomach gets tight you feel frozen you
get stuck you
feel your neck when the body starts to
do that
number one just remember
it means your body is getting ready to
be alert and pay attention doesn't and
it does not mean you're going to lose
control
it does not mean you're in danger it
does not mean to stop or to shut up
i want you to take a deep breath
count to five five four three two one
that's it
and realize that the hormones that just
got released because you're about to do
something they only last 90 seconds
that's it
you can breathe slowly you can count to
90 you can get up and walk around you
can do 90 seconds of jumping jacks
you can meditate for 90 seconds you can
ground your feet in your chair
and wiggle a minute so that you feel
your body in your chair
and take deep breaths and what you're
going to
find is that you're going to be blown
away
you're going to be blown away because
what you're going to see is that
in 90 seconds flat you can go from being
somebody
who has an upset stomach and who would
normally not go talk to your boss who
would
normally not walk into that gym who
would normally
not make that call in 90 seconds flat
you can manipulate your body state to
calm down
and you will notice that your thoughts
do not race your thoughts calm down
you're in full control and now you can
speak up and now you can show up and
here's what's even cooler
by doing this by interrupting the fear
response and the thoughts racing
you're retraining your body response to
situations
the more you do this the less on edge
your body will be
in similar situations habit number four
confront your fears with will smith it's
such a lesson in life right and
part of what i've been doing in my 50th
year um
i've been trying to experience all the
things that i never let myself
experience before and i'm doing you know
my
my bucket list experiences and
sort of what i discovered is how um
how cancerous fear can be
in experiencing a life if you're like
you can't be happy if you're scared
you know so i'm really confronting all
the things
that i've ever been scared of and i'm
just finding this really exuberant
freedom in life you know oh yeah okay
i'm not doing either one okay yeah
you bungee jump this is from a
helicopter from a helicopter y'all
bungee jumped out of a helicopter
over the grand canyon yeah okay so
so now don't do that don't do that right
you should sky dive but don't don't do
that so yeah that was going to say so
then you're hanging there for a while
until the helicopter lands
yeah i did so what i did is they didn't
they did i told them i didn't want to
know anything
so i didn't want any brief i didn't want
anything because we did it live
so i walked up to the helicopter and i
was letting them explain everything to
me in the moment i didn't know
and the first thing i didn't know is i
had to be on the outside of the
helicopter when it took off
right so i'm like hmm
but the camera's on right you know the
camera being your face right and you
know
i'm an action hero so i can't i was like
hmm
you know and that was the first thing
and then the next thing the guy he's
looking at me and he's like listen
he's like this bungee cord there's five
guys holding the bungee cord
he said this bungee cord weighs 200
pounds and when we let it go it's going
to be
the equivalent of four or 500 pounds and
i'm gonna count backwards from five
and on one they're letting this bungee
cord go
and the only way you can get hurt is if
you don't get away from this chopper
right so here he's looking and he's
gonna right
and then i said i can't really i'm
barely hearing them so i'm like
and then i see them go
and i'm like
[Applause]
it's like the other side of not dying is
fantastic
right you know i guess if i died it
would suck but yeah yeah like
the the fact and when the bungee cord
because you go and you go and you go and
you're like
oh please work please work and then it
goes
and there's this brief moment where you
just kind of stop for a second
and you're like wow
[Applause]
then you go but right back into the
right part
like how does that know that would scare
me too that you know
i was like oh wow the chopper is coming
back pretty fast
man oh man no it's uh it's totally
blissful you know it's like fear
fear has committed some of the greatest
atrocities on this planet and
being being clean of fear
is just a really critical aspect i agree
with you
i agree habit number five change your
narrative with simon sinek
i was also watching the olympics and
this is what i i realized this when i
was watching the london olympics so
a couple olympics ago and i was annoyed
by how all the journalists asked all the
athletes
the same stupid question literally
everyone
were you nervous or are you nervous
whether it was before or after the event
every single time
and every single time all the athletes
gave the exact
same answer no i was excited
no i'm excited every single time
these elite athletes had learned to
interpret body stimulus
what is what are the signs of
nervousness your heart races you
visualize
the future you clamp your hands get
clammy what the
what are the stimulus for excitement
your heart races you visualize the
future your hands get clammy
they had learned to interpret what their
body was telling them
not as nerves but as excitement and the
reason the journalists
said were you nervous is because they
would be nervous
[Music]
athletes would never say that to each
other they say that was exciting
so i tried it i did a little test on
myself right
i'm on a plane we start hitting some
really bad turbulence i go
and then i say to myself literally out
loud this is exciting
and i was fine
and i was fine so i do it a lot now
when i find myself getting nervous i say
to myself
this is so exciting and i'll explain the
reason to myself why
so
like an actor you don't get nervous when
you go on stage anymore but occasionally
you do
so i get to go on stage a lot and i
don't really get nervous much anymore
but i was going to present to 3
000 chiefs of police right in the middle
of all this police brutality
uh hullabaloo
and i got really nervous because the
stakes were really high
you know and i was literally getting
nervous backstage
and i said to myself this is so exciting
i have an opportunity to talk to a group
of people who can actually affect change
in this country this is really exciting
now i could have said the same thing i'm
so nervous i'm about to talk to people
who could
but the interpretation was excitement
just change the narrative
it works brilliantly well and habit
number six the last one before very
special
bonus clip is hang out with confident
people with
gary vaynerchuk what is your
biggest secret to become
yeah be more fearless and take chances
to
step up where maybe people are hiding
yep
so you know how earlier i said i don't
know how to teach you empathy
because i don't i used to answer this
question the same way
and then the cool thing about life is
you get wiser you watch
and something breaks through and i
actually have an answer for this
and i'm i don't say it a lot and i'm
super pumped you asked me so thank you
you need to do two things
you need to start hanging out with
people that are overly confident
you need to look around your world
friends of friends
go to meetups look in your office
remember a friend from college or high
school
you need to become friends with more
people that are confident
and tomorrow you have to cut out one of
your friends
who's pessimistic and negative out of
your life
not totally but you don't need to talk
to her or him
three times a day maybe three times a
month
this is an energy game now i've got a
special bonus clip that i think you're
gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i wanna know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and what is your plan of action that
you're going to execute this week
to make some immediate momentum happen
when you just get
motivated and watch a video you have a
chance of following through that's what
the science says but
when you write down what time what day
what place you're actually going to
execute when you create the plan
you have a 91 chance of following
through
and i want that for you and when you
commit to people publicly
you increase your chances even more of
actually doing it
so i want to know what your single
biggest takeaway from this video was
and your specific plan of action
to actually get the result you're after
let me know put it down in the comments
below
because i want to celebrate you
the famous quote of feel the fear and do
it anyway i would change
the feel the fear and do it because of
because if you want to do great things
you have to teach yourself that you do
scary things that you step out of your
comfort zone
that you embrace difficult challenges
that you
do scary things feel the fear and do it
because of
make that your mantra and your entire
life will change
so recently my friend mark drager friend
of the channel long time friend of the
channel
he helped actually film my very first
video on walt disney that was him behind
the camera
he had an idea that he wanted to shave
his head but
he was anxious he was worried he
was fearful of how it might look
of how people might judge him of you
can't go back from it
you know once you once you shave it it's
going to take a while to grow back
and so he decided that he would just do
it
[Music]
why are you videotaping that
what is he doing isn't that crazy it
looks pretty crazy right now
i hope it looks better when it's done
maybe maybe not we'll see
and what i love about this is that he
decided to do the scary thing
that whether he sticks with having his
head shaved or not doesn't matter
it's it's teaching yourself that you do
scary things that when an idea comes
into your head
and the instant voice that comes back is
well that's scary
i don't know if i can do that every
second
that you spend thinking about that and
minutes weeks months years decades for
some people
just sitting on the idea and telling
yourself that it's too scary and you
can't do it
you're teaching yourself that you suck
that's what i believe i really believe
that if
you want to do something you've got an
idea in your head maybe it's shaving
your head maybe it's something else
maybe it's
asking somebody out maybe it's starting
that business maybe it's making that
phone call maybe it's writing that book
or making that video
or starting your instagram account
whatever it is we all have these things
that we fear
deciding that you're going to do it
and that it's not because you're
fearless because you are afraid fear is
a great thing if you're fearless then
you're just inside your comfort zone all
the time think about it if you had no
fears
it means you're just sitting inside your
comfort zone and you're not doing
anything that is remotely scary
it's feeling the fear and saying i do
scary things i'm the kind of person
teaching yourself that you're the kind
of person who follows through
on difficult things on scary things
that's how you build your
self-confidence that's how you build
yourself love
mark shaving his head you might think
well what does have to do with his
business goals
and and progress as an entrepreneur
everything
everything is he going to land more
deals now that he has a shaved head
probably not but the the self love
the self motivation the self confidence
that comes from
teaching yourself if you had that idea
in his head for weeks or months saying i
should do this i should do this and then
he's not doing it he doesn't follow
through
the record in his head is i suck i suck
i suck i suck do you think he's gonna be
bold in business
do you think when he comes up with a new
idea for what he should be doing on
on his campaign on his hiring on his
next step that he's gonna take action
heck no
because that loop is in his head saying
you suck
you come up with ideas and then find
ways why you can't do it you come up
with
bold initiatives and then don't do them
and play small and they just stay as an
idea
you need to flip it you flip it in every
circumstance as long as it's not against
your ethics or
is just plain stupid right like don't
just jump into a lion's cage because
you're scared to do it right most of the
things that you're afraid to do
are not actually against your ethics and
are not actually going to cause physical
harm to you or somebody else
right most of the things you're afraid
to do are revolving other people's
opinions
other people's judgments failing in
front of somebody else and that now is
no longer good enough reason
you have to shift the mindset that when
something comes that's difficult that's
scary that's hard
that you do it you're the kind of person
who comes up with genius
amazing ideas and they have to be
birthed into the world
you do scary things just because
[Music]
if you want to change your life in the
next 30 days for free
check out my training right here below
or if you want to not let fear stop you
from taking action check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there